[Musique]
l'an dernier nos allocations de
pervenche sous son menton 13 secondes ça
m'est déjà arrivé d'être au travail de
voir oyo tels produits dans telle place
de me lever de ma chaise de partir on
prend la voiture ans on arrive qu'il
reste plus rien des jeux
malgré les 2 millions de bouteilles
vendues principalement dans leur
vignoble les vignerons du québec ont
beaucoup de difficultés à répondre
demain en peut-être sa peine dix ans on
est passé d'une situation où les vient
aux québécois partent avec leur bâton de
pèlerin essayer de vendre leurs
bouteilles puis convainquent un
restaurateur de le mettre sur la carte
puis à des marchés publics et des
marchés de noël à une situation c'est
l'inversé on retient les bouteilles on
limite les quantités par personne et
frénésie avait débuté bien avant la
pandémie c'est sûr que la pandémie a
accéléré quelque chose qui était déjà en
route effectivement pour le discours en
général d'achat local
mais c'était déjà bien parti et
effectivement c'est cette demande qui
aurait cru qu'un jour on va encore une
fois du vin en mettre en bouteille qu'on
vendrait par internet c'est quand même
incroyable
on achète une bouteille une fois par la
curiosité ou parce que parce que notre
premier ministre a cité à le faire mais
la deuxième fois on leur achète parce
qu'on le trouvait bon et si les verts
sont en rupture de stock depuis plus de
18 mois c'est parce qu'ils sont bons
il y a vingt ans le vin québécois avait
une réputation à construire internet en
était à ses débuts les réseaux sociaux
tels qu'on les connaît n'existait pas
aujourd'hui des amateurs n'hésite pas à
payer 30 $ la bouteille pour des vins de
petits vignobles tendance la qualité la
rareté et le côté artisanal en
justifiant le prix on casse du sucre
beaucoup dans les médias sociaux mais il
ya aussi plein de beaux côtés qui
permettent aux gens de on leur a donné
un certain accès à ce qu'on fait à nos
réflexions à notre quotidien quand
j'achète de 7 mais je vois si j'achète
aussi un lieu j'achète une histoire
j'achète une démarche et biologique ou
environnementale etc donc il n'y a rien
comme le contact humain
[Musique]
dans cette épicerie fine où l'on ne vend
que du vin du québec on constate que le
profil de la clientèle a changé on parle
quand même d'une nouvelle génération
donc des 25-35 ans l'autre génération le
vont re découvrir les vins du québec
parce que il y en avait beaucoup qui ont
découvert les vins du québec d'ici une
quinzaine d'années s'était pas tout à
fait là encore le maintenant une belle
évolution
jérémy fait partie de la nouvelle
génération de consommateurs de vins du
québec ça passe beaucoup par la mission
même du vignoble les gens derrière le
vin le fait que ça soit vraiment un
produit qui soit dit nature c'est
principalement sur son cellulaire que la
recherche de vins super on a des groupes
instagram des groupes facebook où on se
passe les nouvelles il y en a un que
qu'à l'occasion d'aller acheter des
bouteilles il y en a qui lui qui le
premier à avoir un effet l'être il
réserve une quête foncé par une caisse à
gags
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un foule est au début quand on a
commencé ça c'était pour faire une
espèce de listes d'attentes partager nos
nouveautés avoir quelques abonnés mais
maintenant les rendez à 10000 abonnés
sur certains fall est là
infolettre liste d'envoi listes d'appels
tous des moyens devenus indispensables
pour joindre le client dont le vit
aujourd'hui en cette peine aussi on a
sorti des cuvées au printemps il ya des
gens qui sont un peu crus d'arriver à
l'automne et de peut avoir accès c'est
donc là c'est ce que l'on met en place
des listes d'appels ou d'envoi pour les
prévenir donc on n'aurait jamais pensé
ça il ya quelques années faudra qu'elle
et les consommateurs déjà comprennent
que c'est un produit artisanal et que
c'est un produit qui est dépendant du
vignoble
on a une récolte par année ça se passe
maintenant et puis il faut attendre un
an avant d'avoir des nouveaux raisin
pour produire des nouveaux donc il
faudra que les consommateurs prennent
leur mal en patience
l'engouement pour le vin québécois ne
repose pas seulement sur une bonne mise
en marché l'expérience des vignerons
québécois acquise au cours des 40
dernières années pour te fuis on dit
toujours que le temps ne pardonne jamais
ce que l'on fait sans lui c'est bien
vrai dans le domaine du vin donc ça
c'est aussi une raison importante pour
laquelle ça a pris du temps à développer
son savoir faire
je pense que c'est indéniable il ya un
bond qualitatif énorme qui était fait
dans les vignobles québécois depuis 10
12 ans
des meilleurs équipements des meilleures
techniques aux chants des meilleures
techniques de vinification mais surtout
aussi je pense à un plus grand respect
du terroir une volonté de présenter le
vin québécois comme quelque chose de
différent d'une unique qui est
résolument ancré dans notre climat nos
sols et bien encore une fois se rend
compte que l'un des standards
internationaux aujourd'hui qu'on n'avait
pas il faut soit fois devant il ya vingt
ans
quand il faut le savoir faire
aujourd'hui est là
donc on n'a pas à rougir de ce que l'on
fait aujourd'hui le vin québécois
goukoye portois on peut décrire je goûte
le terroir to go to si le froid les vins
au québec bon on parle d'un climat avec
votre qui meurt dit donc plus froid donc
c'est ça va toujours avoir une belle
acidité qui voit
il faut retenir que ce sont des vins de
climat frais avec une belle acidité une
cité croquante bien fraîche et puis il
faut il faut l'accepter il faut
l'apprivoiser c'est vrai il ya un goût
aux vins québécois mais les gens ont
fait un bout de chemin pour comprendre
pourquoi aussi le vin québécois écoutent
comme cette espèce de rencontre à
mi-chemin de compréhension aussi good
hit soit comprendre la démarche